la pandemia de los no vacunados así fue
como lo llamó la directora del centro de
control y prevención de enfermedades de
eeuu
rosell wilensky esta semana al referirse
a la evolución que está teniendo el
coronavirus en países con altas tasas de
disponibilidad de vacunas se están
viviendo nuevos brotes y cada vez más
entre los no vacunados eeuu con un 49
punto 6 por ciento de la población
vacunada registró un incremento en las
últimas semanas del 70 por ciento de
casos de kobe
la desinformación en salud llevó a que
la gente se resista a usar mascarillas
en lugares de riesgo de no usar
tratamientos probados y escoger no
vacunarse esto llevó a inevitables
enfermedades y muertes la desinformación
nos ha costado vidas
mientras tanto en francia con el 44% de
la población inoculada según a world in
their a registró un aumento de contagios
entre aquellos que no están vacunados
1496 200 de los 18 mil nuevos casos
encontramos que en esos casos
era gente no vacunada máximo el caso
similar en españa el 83 por ciento de
los contagios recientes son en personas
sin vacunar como lo señaló esta semana
el ministerio de sanidad la diferencia
es que la aceptación de las vacunas en
el país ibérico es más amplia entre la
población por encima del 90% según las
últimas encuestas y en alemania las
personas no vacunadas podrán enfrentar
mayores restricciones que los inoculados
si los casos siguen en aumento en este
país